a refugee crisis on an industrial scale
every person currently housed in this
warehouse on the ukraine poland border
had their lives turned upside down when
russia invaded ukraine
the number of people forced to live like
this offers an insight into the enormous
scope of this crisis
and still they keep coming bust in from
the border
away from the war but now in limbo
we're here at one of the many reception
centers set up on the ukraine poland
border where people have been telling us
how happy and relieved they are to
finally be inside poland to have crossed
over the border from ukraine but many
people have also been telling us of the
indignities that they have suffered on
the ukrainian side of the border
people from countries in asia africa and
the middle east were living and working
in ukraine when the war began
weapons of war do not discriminate so
everyone ran for their lives foreign
citizens hoping to reach poland to
contact diplomatic missions evacuated to
warsaw
we were already the last people together
to get on anything it was always like
that so
they will firstly put their people first
and us i would say for me it was
discriminating but i think for them it's
normal because it's their country they
need to save their people first some of
the people we spoke with said a country
at war could be forgiven for putting
their own people first but for others
some with ukrainian families of their
own the contrast of how they were
treated was too stark
we understand that they need to save
their citizens but we have been loyal to
ukraine we have been in their country we
have been lawful in their country we
have shown them love i believe that the
least they could do was to evacuate us
well my thought is that a refugee is a
refugee and a refugee is a human being
and it doesn't matter what what
skin color religion political
attitude or whatever that is if a
refugee needs help then we need to help
a refugee
the non-european refugees coming into
poland tell stories of generous
strangers giving help shelter food and
transport
but they also tell stories of guns being
pointed at them by ukrainian troops
being forced back to make way for
ukrainians to get to safe havens first
and even in poland tempers run high
wait no you can't tell us
the same way that we went out of florida
even ukrainians went out
only you're taking just ukrainians i'm
so sorry i respect you as a police
officer but what you guys are doing here
this is not the job of a country that is
showing itself that they are helping
refugees coming from ukraine
i'm sorry war as always it seems brings
out the best and worst in people
and even if the fighting stops soon
repairing the damage done to all the
lives touched by this crisis
will take much longer
zain basravi al-jazeera corchova eastern
poland